rostros felices atuendos ligeros y
música alegre la vida nocturna ha
retomado su curso en barcelona la
reapertura de las discotecas marca el
regreso de los turistas a la capital de
la fiesta
hemos estado en cuarentena durante tanto
tiempo es increíble estar aquí estamos
felices finalmente es verano para esta
discoteca es el final del túnel después
de 15 meses de cierre el establecimiento
casi que ahora ha sido muy duro para
todos como los primeros en cerrar como
cero torno y estamos siendo los últimos
en abrir entonces si una pandemia
afectado a tal nivel la sociedad
española' imagínense cómo afecta a los
primeros que cerramos y a los últimos
que abriremos últimamente con la
evolución de la vacunación que está
siendo muy amplio a nivel europeo
las expectativas son mejores hay
optimismo a pesar de algunas
restricciones vigentes como el indicador
del 50% de la capacidad de recepción o
la obligación de llevar una mascarilla
para bailar en cataluña las discotecas
también tendrán que cerrar antes a las 3
y 30 de la mañana sin embargo es
insuficiente para estropear la fiesta de
que esto vuelva un poquito a la
normalidad de antes aunque nos gustaría
que abriesen hasta un poquito más tarde
eso sería ideal si volviese todo hasta
las 6 de la mañana 7 ya vamos bien
poco a poco poco a poco está bien estas
medidas se volverán a evaluar durante
las próximas dos semanas y si todos los
indicadores están en verde la gente en
barcelona finalmente podrá bailar hasta
la madrugada